BEST-CASE SCENARIO IF NO
AMERICANS LOST THEIR LIVES
TONIGHT.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
THIS JUST IN.
FOOTAGE OF ME.
THE AIRBASE WE ARE TALKING ABOU
ABOUT.
THE AL-ASSAD AIRBASE.
IN 2006, I WENT THERE AND GOT TO
KNOW THESE GUYS.
I LOOKED A LITTLE YOUNGER.
MY HAIR WAS A LITTLE DARKER.
THESE ARE OUR BRAVE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT WERE UNDER FIRE.
HERE WITH THE REAL
HERE WITH THE REACTION LIVE FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR, A LOT HAS
CHANGED SINCE THE CONFLICT FROM
IRAQ AND THE CONFLICT WITH
AFGHANISTAN.
IT GETS POLITICIZED IN THAT TOWN
YOU LIVE IN.
WE SEND THESE KIDS TO FIGHT,
BLEED, AND DIED.
THEY FIGHT AND THEY GIVE THEIR
HEART AND WE DECIDE NEVER MIND.
THAT HAS CHANGED MY ATTITUDE
ABOUT ANY FUTURE CONFLICT.
I BELIEVE IT'S CHANGED YOURS
TOO.
THE PRESIDENT IS CLEAR, THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO BE LONG CONFLICTS
AND OUR MILITARY IS STRONGER
THAN EVER.
>> YEAH, WELCOME OF THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO DO IS THINK
THOSE THAT ARE SERVING IN
UNIFORM IN THE MIDEAST.
YOU ARE THE VIRTUAL WALL BETWEEN
US AND RADICAL ISLAM.
WE CAN BUILD A WALL ALONG OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT YOU CAN
BUILD A WALL BETWEEN US AND
RADICAL ISLAM.
YOU NEED SOME OF OUR PEOPLE
WORKING TO KEEP THESE AT BAY.
I HAVE COMPLETE CONFIDENCE IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM TO
PROTECT YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
TO PROTECT OUR NATION.
THIS IS THE FIRST PRESIDENT IN
THE LAST 40 YEARS WHO REALLY
UNDERSTANDS THE IRANIANS.
THIS WAS AN ACT OF WAR, SEAN,
THAT DELL MIGHT BY ANY
REASONABLE DEFINITION.
THE MISSILES WERE LAUNCHED FROM
IRAN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALL THE
AUTHORITY HE NEEDS UNDER ARTICLE
TWO TO RESPOND.
HOW HE RESPONDS IS YET TO BE
REDETERMINED
DEDETERMINED
DETETERMINED
DETERMRMINED
DETERMININED
DETERMINEDED
DETERMINED.D
IT WAS AN ACT OF WAR BY THE
REGIME FOR THE LAST 40 YEARS.
IT'S BEEN A CANCER IN THE
MIDEAST.
WHEN THEY SAY THEY WANT TO
DESTROY ISRAEL, THEY ARE NOT
KIDDING.
SO, THE PRESIDENT HAS TO DO A
COUPLE THINGS TONIGHT.
WHAT CAN I DO TO RESTORE
DETERRENCE TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN?
HE DOESN'T WANT REGIME CHANGE.
HE WANTS THE BEHAVIOR OF THE
REGIME TO CHANGE IN THREE AREAS.
THEIR BALLISTIC MISSILE PROGRAM
NEEDS TO CHANGE.
TRUMP IS NOT GOING TO BE KIND BY
THE IRANIANS.
HIS RESPONSE IS TO DEAL WITH
THOSE THREE BUCKETS.
>> Sean: BY THE WAY, I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A LOT OF CREDIT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THESE WARRIORS
WHO HAVE PUT THEIR SELVES
WHO HAVE PUT THEIR TELVES
WHO HAVE PUT THEIR TOLVES
WHO HAVE PUT THEIR TO TES
WHO HAVE PUT THEIR TO THEMSELVES
IN HARM'S WAY.
IF THE IRANIANS WANT REGIME
CHANGE, THAT WILL HAVE TO COME
FROM THE PEOPLE.
BOOTS ON THE GROUNDS, AMERICANS
KNOCKING ON DOORS AND GETTING
BLOWN UP.
THAT'S GOT TO END, BECAUSE
WASHINGTON POLITICIZED AS THESE
WORDS.
HERE'S MY QUESTION.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT REGIME CHANGE.
THIS IS ABOUT A CHANGE IN
BEHAVIOR.
THE PRESIDENT IN MY VIEW FRANKLY
SHOWED MORE RESTRAINT THAN I
WOULD HAVE WHEN THEY SHOT DOWN
OUR DRONES, WHEN THEY TOOK THOSE
TANKERS HOSTAGE, WHEN THEY
ATTACKED THE SAUDIS.
HOW MANY AMERICANS DO WE NOW
KNOW THAT SOLEIMANI IN
PARTICULAR KILLED IN IRAQ?
THIS BEHAVIOR WILL GET A
REACTION AND THAT IS JUST THE
WAY THE WORLD WORKS.
IF WE DON'T REACT, WE ARE ONLY
BASICALLY INCENTIVIZING MORE OF
IT.
>> WELL, WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED?
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TR
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TY
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TF
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TS
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 TT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN GO FROM 0 T.
HE ABSORBED THE DRONE SAYING, IT
WAS JUST A DRONE.
IT WAS A PRETTY SMART MOVE.
THEY GO AFTER THE LARGEST OIL
FIELD IN THE WORLD AND
SAUDI ARABIA DISRUPTING ALL OIL
PRICES AND THE PRESIDENT HELD
BACK.
I CAN TELL YOU, I WAS WITH HIM
WHEN ALL THAT HAPPEN.
WHEN THEY KILLED OUR CONTRACTOR,
THAT CHANGED EVERYTHING.
AMERICA FIRST MEANS TO ME, YOU
KILL AN AMERICAN, YOU ARE GOING
TO BE THE FIRST ONE WE COME
AFTER.
THESE MISSILES DID NOT KILL AN
AMERICAN TONIGHT, I HOPE, BUT
THE PRESIDENT IS VERY METHODICA
METHODICAL.
HE'S GOT ONE OF THE BEST
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAMS THAT
I'VE SEEN SINCE I'VE BEEN UP
HERE.
WE ARE DEALING WITH RELIGIOUS
NAZIS.
THEY HAVE BEEN DISRUPTING THE
MIDEAST FOR 40 YEARS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS.
THERE MAY BE A MIND-SET.
I KNOW WE HAVE THE BENGHAZI
DEMOCRATS.
Y0
YOU CAN RESTART YOUR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
IT'S PROBABLY ONE OF THE DUMBEST
DEALS EVER.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT POINT.
THE LAST CENTURY, WE LOST
100 MILLION HUMAN SOULS.
FASCISM, NAZISM, STALIN, OVER
100 MILLION SOULS.
I DON'T WANT WARS AND I DON'T
WANT BOOTS ON THE GROUND.
I WOULD ARGUE THAT YOU NEVER DO
THAT AGAIN.
BUT WHEN THEY, WHEN YOU ARE
DEALING WITH A SICK TWISTED
IDEOLOGIES THAT WOULD STRAP
BOMBS ON CHILDREN AND TELL THEM
TO GO KILL AMERICANS AND
ISRAELIS, I DON'T SEE HOW YOU
BEGIN TO NEGOTIATE AT ANY LEVEL
WITH THAT KIND OF SICK UGLY EVIL
MIND-SET.
DO YOU?
>> WELL, THIS REGIME IS PROBABLY
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN --
HE'S ON A RELIGIOUS QUEST TO
DESTROY THE WORLD AND CHANGE IT
TO A CERTAIN FORM OF RADICAL
ISLAM.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT, I
THINK UNDERSTANDS ABOUT THE
IRANIANS.
THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO CHANGE
UNTIL YOU MAKE THEM CHANGE.
FOR THE LAST 40 YEARS, THEY HAVE
BEEN WREAKING HAVOC ON THE
WORLD.
HERE'S WHAT I THINK IS GOING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT TONIGHT.
WHAT DO I NEED TO DO TOMORROW OR
THE NEXT DAY TO GET THEM BACK
INTO A DETERRENT MODE SO THAT
THEY WILL LEAVE US ALONE AND HOW
DO I GET THEM TO CHANGE THEIR
MISSILE PROGRAM TO GET A BETTER
DEAL ON THEIR NUCLEAR PROGRAM SO
THEY WANT HAVE A PATHWAY AND
WHAT CAN I DO TO STOP THEM FROM
BEING THE LARGEST SPONSOR OF
TERRORISM?
THE PRICE HAS TO GO UP BEFORE
THEY WILL CHANGE.
THE PRESIDENT ISN'T LOOKING FOR
A REGIME CHANGE, BUT HE IS
LOOKING FOR --
LET ME SAY TONIGHT, IF YOU ARE
WATCHING TELEVISION IN IRAN.
I JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
YOUR FATE IS IN YOUR OWN HANDS
IN TERMS OF THE REGIME'S